home furniture starting pitcher
j.a happ making his 19th start of the
season
coming off a pretty good start in his
last appearance against the angels so a
busted bat single now a two out walk and
candelario will bat
got him and that wraps up the first
inning a lot of pitches but the tigers
leave too no score
after a half and like matt shepard just
said willie peralta making his eighth
start looking for a bounce back after
his last outing in kansas city he's done
well against the twins
it's seven strong innings not too long
ago against the twins
and gets caught looking on the inside
corner kepler disagrees
there's jorge polanco now the 3-1 from
peralta
slapped fair to harold castro at first
and that's a one two three first for
willy peralta
back to back one out singles for the
tigers and here's grayson griner
on the ground and through the left side
for a base hit
they're gonna weigh willy castro home
the throw is cut off he's in there
sliding safely
an rbi single for grayson griner the
bottom feeders for the tigers
give them first blood in minnesota today
so two on one out here's toward
third out there and no chance to get
purdue at first
two away so here's derrick hill who
grounded back to jhap his first time up
squares to bunt lays it down that's a
safety squeeze and they won't get him at
first base
early in the ball game element's a
surprise you grab an extra 90 feet pick
up a run that's just
great hunting and for the second time in
as many days
eric hoss will bat with the bases loaded
swings and rips one to right field and
deep in the corner larnick back on the
wall he'll jump
up and larnick makes an unbelievable
catch
with his back slamming against the
padding in right field
probably saved two if not three runs
that's going to load the bases
two outs and simmons at the plate
on the ground to short they'll get the
easy play at second
and minnesota leaves them loaded again
willie peralta a little bit of damage
control there in the second
two away here's jorge polanco polanco
first pitch swinging
same result to harold castro second one
two three
inning for willie peralta just eight
pitches
that'll help congress have two men on as
the lineup turns over for kill badou
down the first base line that's a fair
ball
played by kepler off the extension
castro trouts home
the tigers lead is now three on an rbi
double from akil badu thrusting himself
into the american league rookie of the
year conversation
on a daily basis it's 1-1 to derek hill
on the ground and off the glove of jorge
polanco another run is home
hill is safe the tigers have him at the
corners and they now lead at four
nothing in the four gets this ball hard
one hopper to blanco and he kind of
lays it to his right it's off his glove
tees it up for robbie grossman
one line to right that's a base hit and
an rbi for robbie grossman but due
easily scores
the line keeps moving for the tigers
it's 5-0 detroit
bases are loaded first six have reached
here in the fourth inning now the payoff
candelario on a line to left and that's
going to get over the head of rooker and
bounce off the wall
plenty of runs coming home on the jamer
candelario solid hit the tigers
open up the lead even more it's a
two-run double for candelario
7-0 detroit see if he can maybe inside
out a little bit
go that way there it is to right center
field
gordon's behind it haas tags that's a
sacrifice fly from zach short candelario
moves up as well
it's now eight nothing tigers and now
willy castro
the tigers bat around castro golfs one
to right center field gordon will watch
it bounce
off the wall candelario trots home
willie castro hustling all the way to
third he's got himself an rbi
triple wow this has just been one of
those innings
this is definitely a pleasant welcome
for the tigers
castro sends a fly ball into center
should score the run
gordon's got it castro
comes home it's now ten nothing
detroit mcgill will lead off he walked
his only advantage
driven hard to center field
and the twins are on the board a bullet
over hill over the fence and into
the junipers number 16 versus twins with
the bases loaded and nobody out
batterby jeffers high fly
center field hill is back
another grand slam
a slam that has cut the tiger lead at
the start of this ending in half
right he sets 2-1 line drive one opera
knocks the glove off of candelario
no play left the bat 106 miles an hour
in the third baseman candelario tried to
backhand it haven't seen that too often
base is loaded here's to no base head
left field kepler scoring
everyone else holding and it's ten to
six
here's ostadio man to bat here in this
half inning
the 2-1 to us to deal with him a favor
how can they force out second barely in
time spaces
are loaded jorge polanco batting from
his stronger right side
steps to the plate he got him swinging
that was huge just overpowering polanco
in the last two pitches with fastballs
back-to-back walks runners aboard for
the tigers the 01 to zach short
down the third base line fair ball into
the corner
haas is going to score zach short
sends candelario all to third he's got
an rbi double
and the tigers increase their lead 11 to
six
walk walk double tigers with a chance to
continue to add on
in the air to center
is it deep enough candelario tags the
throw comes into third
it's a sacrifice fly for willy castro
it's now a 12-6
tigers lead and there are now two away
here comes the number nine hitter in
grayson griner
fly ball deep right center field that's
got some carry to it that's going to go
off the wall
short easily scores grayson griner have
a day
his fourth multi-hit game of the season
make it 13-6
tigers
nice play by candelario he cuts it off
and throws out
simmons to retire the twins one two
three
job well done by buck farmer kepler
leads off against buck farmer
high fly to right field
and kepler has another one
into the second deck and kepler's 14th
of the year draws the twins one more
run closer here's rooker drive to left
there's another home run
only the second debt today for
brett rooker but his third of the series
and the fourth home run of the day for
the twins joe jimenez
in the face miguel ceno with polanco at
first base and the twins are down by
five runs
well up into the third deck so
16th of the year 17th of here
his second today and that's one of the
longest home runs ever hit here at
target field
so two outs and here comes jeffers a
drive to
left center field do you believe this
it's a one-run game the fourth home run
of the inning
and it's 13-12. eric
gets to bat with the bases loaded for
the third time in the last two days
here's the 2-0 sharply past
the third baseman on studio into the
left field corner
one run is home here comes derek hill
robbie grossman is being waved home
he scores that is a three-run
double for eric haas now the 1-2 to
candelario
fly ball center field
and diving ground and then dropped by
rooker
candelario all the way to second high
scores
it's now 17-12 tigers here's polanco now
he's been on
twice a single little walk in a run a
high drive left field
but back and that one's gone polanco
joins the home run parade
i've seen a lot of crazy baseball games
in my time
a lot but this one's definitely going to
rank right up there with some of the
crazier ones
soto against willens osterrio now the o2
grounded to third it is
over the tigers hold on and beat the
twins in a wild one
[Music]
17-14